kim ledbeter knows politics can be
dangerous
she wears a panic alarm and is often
accompanied in public by police
because six years ago her sister joe cox
was murdered outside a constituency
surgery
now representing the same seat she
remembers clearly the emotion of the day
sir david amos was murdered
shock
on two levels i think one
oh my gosh how has this happened again
and then to the shock of sort of being
taken back to 2016.
and
what really resonated with me in that
regard was knowing what his family
were going through
and the horrific journey that they would
have just started on that day
she believes the abuse mps receive is
worse than many realize things are
pretty bad um and what scares me and
worries me is the fact that we've
normalized that
and as mps we've normalized it so i work
with some really strong women
but even they are saying you know
talk while talking about court cases
restraining orders
as if it's normal as if that's okay as
if we would put up with that in any
other job
in the last six months cabinet minister
michael gove has been swarmed by
anti-vaxx protesters
labour leader sakir stama had a similar
experience both now have police
protection but security experts argue
the danger is often being too open
a lot of the times the biggest challenge
for these people is is actually
themselves with what they post on social
media they literally put their whole
lives out there and and it's all there
for the world to see
kim ledbeter believes mps need
compulsory security training but argues
support from the police and parliament
is getting better do you feel safe
i feel safe most of the time
but one of the reasons i feel safe is
because i take
everything that's offered to me in terms
of security and support
if i didn't have that support
i would feel a lot less safe i knew
there were going to be risks associated
with this job
probably more than anybody
but
when
a colleague is murdered
those risks become very very
clear
joe pike's sky news heckman wike west
yorkshire
but again i think